winter storm warnings are in effect
across the Pacific Northwest this
morning as cold winds and snowy weather
spread from the Sierra Nevada to
Washington State and Northwest Montana
as much as eight inches of snow fell on
some Seattle suburbs Friday causing
hazardous travel conditions for many
drivers in other parts of the state snow
flurries blanketed residential
neighborhoods transforming local
landscapes into seas of white Carter
Evans is in Seattle with the latest
Carter good morning I believe
Snowmageddon may be one of the terms
they've used for this one good morning
it's a cold morning here and this is an
unusual sight in Seattle we're at the
world-famous Pike Street Market and you
can see about three to four inches of
snow on the ground already with another
two to six inches in the forecast by the
time this is all done governor jay
Inslee has declared a state of emergency
one county official called this storm a
once in a decade or two event now about
six inches of snow fell at sea-tac
airport a snowball fight unfolded
between workers on the tarmac it's an
unusual sight there at least 200 flights
were canceled to accommodate the winter
weather people cleared grocery store
shelves as they rushed to prepare one
person described fights breaking out at
crowded checkout lines and as the storm
moved in it obscured the city's famous
Space Needle in Seattle's Queen Anne
neighborhood last night
well one bus had to bail off its route
after it got stuck on a snow-covered
Street overnight some roads were closed
all together now more flight
cancellations are expected today there's
at least 80 so far and this is not over
yet
we're expecting to get storm through the
early morning hours and then on Sunday
another storm could come through and
that could bring even more snow for the
Monday commute Anthony you know pretty
stunning images from Seattle Carter
Evans things cutter I've kind of shocked
at those pictures